madame la Première ministre notre pays a
vécu ces derniers jours des heures
effroyables rien rien ne peut justifier
de s'attaquer à des écoles à des
bibliothèques à des locaux d'association
qui œuvrent pour le bien commun nos
concitoyens voient leurs voitures
brûlées des commerçants leur magasin
pillés des policiers des élus et parfois
même de simples passants qui se trouvent
au mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
sont attaqués sauvagement je tiens
d'ores et déjà à saluer au nom du groupe
horizon et apparenter le travail
exceptionnel réalisé par nos forces de
secours et de sécurité elles ont souvent
été mobilisées sur des territoires qui
n'étaient pas les leurs dans les
conditions extrêmement difficiles que
nous connaissons tous
nous souhaitons aussi rendre hommage à
l'engagement sans faille dont font
preuve nos élus de terrain qui refusent
de reculer face aux menaces et
agressions mes chers collègues il n'y a
aucune revendication sociale à trouver
dans ces agissements inacceptables
aucune colère légitime aucune excuse
mais seulement un acte des actes de
Sécession d'une minorité qui rejette
toute forme d'autorité ces rejets de
l'ordre républicains se font au
détriment de dizaines de millions de
Français qui n'ont qu'une seule envie
une seule demande celle d'un cadre de
vie paisible pour eux et pour leur
famille comment par ailleurs ne pas être
interloqué par le jeune âge des
individus interpellés que font ces
mineurs seuls parfois toute la nuit dans
la rue où sont leurs parents titulaires
de l'autorité parentale et chargée de
veiller tant à leur éducation qu'à leur
sécurité qui surveille l'attitude et
l'activité de ces jeunes sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur Internet
madame la Première ministre notre
capacité à faire nation et gravement
menacée par ces événements récents
comment comptez-vous réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'État et la primauté du
pacte républicain face à des individus
qui semblent prêts à tout pour faire
régner le chaos merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Laurent Marc Angelli vous avez
raison de le dire les violences de ces
derniers jours sont inacceptables et je
veux à nouveau rendre hommage à nos
policiers nos gendarmes nos
sapeurs-pompiers dont le courage est
exceptionnel face aux violences de ces
derniers jours
notre priorité c'est de garantir le
retour au calme et d'assurer la sécurité
de tous les Français et comme l'a dit le
président de la République nous devons
aussi engager une réflexion sur les
causes profondes de cette situation et
la représentation nationale il prendra
naturellement toute sa part nous
examinerons tous les sujets sans
exception sans tabou ni faux semblant
nous devons notamment assurer le respect
de l'autorité en général et de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale nous
devons mieux réguler les réseaux sociaux
et vous aurez l'occasion d'examiner
prochainement un texte visant à mieux
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
et comme l'a dit le président de la
République nous devons renforcer nos
réponses en sanctionnant les jeunes dès
le premier écart avec vous monsieur le
Président Marc Angeli avec l'ensemble
des députés de la majorité avec toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent construire
des solutions
refuseront les caricatures et les idées
toutes faites notre objectif c'est
l'efficacité dans les réponses ce sont
les solutions pour les habitants des
quartiers pour les habitants de tous nos
territoires et pour notre jeunesse notre
ambition c'est l'unité de la République
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la Première ministre
[Musique]